la secte c'est devenir une fourmi dans
une fourmilière que jamais en sortir
est ce que par hasard vous avez entendu
parler de la brigade des loups
d'après nos sources la brigade des loups
seraient une équipe secrète chargée d
élimination
[Musique]
c'est ça notre métier je vais m'en
occuper il a suivi un traitement
psychologique il ya cinq ans
ils veulent montrer qu'ils s'attaquent à
l'unité spéciale
mais ça ne m'étonnerait pas qu'il vise
beaucoup plus haut
que de ma situation pourquoi tu fais
autant d'histoires aller en toi
la fillette avec vous les pas encore
tout à fait confiance à personne
[Musique]
nous sommes pas des hommes habillés en
lourd
pelloux habillée en homme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qui est responsable de la mort de
la jeune fille le pire
ce que nous ne savons pas
guy arrière
[Musique]